[Music]
the teacher of christianity acts like a
person who promises to restore patients
to bodily health but who prevents them
from consulting skilled physicians by
whom his ignorance would be exposed
christians weave together erroneous
opinions drawn from ancient sources and
sound them before men as the priests of
sibilly clash their symbols in the ears
of those who are being initiated in
their mysteries
a few years ago he began to teach the
doctrine being regarded by christians as
the son of god
he invented his birth from a virgin and
was disgracefully born in a certain
jewish village of a poor woman of the
country who gained her subsistence by
spinning she was turned out of doors by
the carpenter to whom she'd been
betrothed having been guilty of adultery
and that she bore a child to a certain
soldier named pantera
that after being driven away by her
husband and wandering about for a time
she disgracefully gave birth to jesus an
illegitimate child who having hired
himself out as a servant in egypt on
account of his poverty and having there
acquired some miraculous powers on which
the egyptians greatly pride themselves
returned to his own country highly
elated on account of them and by means
of these proclaimed himself
a god
seeing you are so eager for some novelty
how much better it would have been if
you were chosen as the object of your
zealous homage
someone of those who died a glorious
death and whose divinity might have
received the support of some myth to
perpetuate his mystery why if you were
not satisfied with hercules or
escalapius and other heroes of antiquity
you had orpheus who was confessedly a
divinely inspired man who died of
violent death how much more suitable
than he would have been jonah in the
whale's belly or daniel delivering from
the wild beasts or any of still more
portentous kind
you mock and revile the statues of our
gods but if you had reviled bacchus or
hercules in person you would not perhaps
have done so with impunity but those who
crucified your god when present among
men suffered nothing for it either at
the time or during the whole of their
lives and what new thing has there
happened since then to make us believe
that he was not an impostor but the son
of god
if the christians would be willing to
answer my questions which i do not put
as one who is trying to understand their
beliefs for i know them all all would be
well
but if they will not consent but say as
they usually do do not ask questions and
so on then it will be necessary to teach
them the nature of the doctrines which
they affirm and the source from which
they come
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
question in today's dollars what was the
gdp per capita of the roman empire
a 100
b a thousand dollars or c
10 000
that's right it's b estimates vary from
600 to 1800
less or more than you thought let me
know in the comments and so my
recommendation this video is one of
magellan's new documentaries which they
add every week one of the incredible 21
part series ancient warriors that covers
units from across the world legions of
rome examines the highly disciplined
soldiers of the roman empire and just
what made them so overwhelmingly
successful in their day
and of course magellan have more than 3
000 other documentaries to check out too
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
[Music]
why should it be he alone rather than
innumerable others who existed after the
prophecies were published
to whom the predictions are applicable
the christian believers like persons who
in a fit of drunkenness lay violent
hands upon themselves have corrupted the
gospel from its original integrity to a
threefold and four-fold and manifold
degree and have remodeled it that they
might be able to answer objections
chaldeans are spoken of by jesus as
having been induced to come to him at
his birth and to worship him while yet
an infant as a god and to have made this
known to herod the tetrarch
and that the latter sent and slew all
the infants that had been born about the
same time thinking that in this way he
would ensure his death among the others
and that he was led to do this through
fear that if jesus lived to a sufficient
age he would obtain
the throne
but if then this was done in order that
he might not reign in his stead when he
had grown to man's estate
why after he did reach that estate did
he not become a king
instead the son of god wandering about
in so mean a condition hiding himself
through fear and leading a miserable
life up and down
jesus having gathered around him 10 or
11 persons of notorious character the
very wickedest of tax gatherers and
fishermen who had not acquired even the
merest elements of learning fled in
company with them from place to place
and obtained his living in a shameful
and important manner
well let us believe that these cures or
the resurrection or the feeding of a
multitude with a few loaves from which
many fragments remained over all those
other stories of a marvelous nature were
actually wrought by him
these are nothing more than the tricks
of jugglers who profess to do more
wonderful things and to the feats
performed by those who have been taught
by egyptians who in the middle of the
marketplace in return for a few hobbles
will impart the knowledge of their most
venerated arts and will expel demons
from men and dispel diseases and invoke
the souls of heroes and exhibit
expensive banquets and tables and dishes
and dainties having no real existence
and who will put in motion as if alive
what are not really living animals but
which have only the appearance of life
since then these persons can perform
such feats shall we of necessity
conclude that they are sons of god
yet how many others are there who
practice such juggling tricks in order
to deceive their simple hearers and who
make gain by their deception or do you
imagine the statements of others not
only to be myths but to have the
appearance of such while you have
discovered a becoming incredible
termination to your drama in the voice
from the cross when he breathed his last
and in the earthquake and the darkness
but that when dead he rose again and
showed the marks of his punishment and
how his hands were pierced with nails
and who beheld this
a half frantic woman as you state and
some other one perhaps of those who were
engaged in the same system of delusion
or which is most probable one who
desired to impress others with this
portent
one who was a god could never flee or be
led away as prisoner and least of all
could he be deserted and delivered up by
those who had been his associates
the disciples of jesus having no
undoubted fact on which to rely devised
the fiction that he foreknew everything
before it happened
how is it credible that jesus could have
predicted these things
and how could the dead man be immortal
what god or spirit or prudent man would
not on foreseeing that such events were
to befall him avoid them if he could
whereas he threw himself headlong into
these things which he knew beforehand
were to happen
how is it that if jesus pointed out
beforehand the traitor and the perjurer
they did not fear him as a god and cease
the one from his intended treason and
the other
from his perjury
in the next place those who were his
associates while alive and who listened
to his voice and enjoyed his
instructions as their teacher on seeing
him subjected to punishment and death
neither died with him nor for him nor
even induced to regard punishment with
contempt but denied even that they were
his disciples
whereas now
you
die along with him
[Music]
judaism upon which christianity depends
is barbarous in its origin they deserve
credit for their ability in discovering
true doctrines but the greeks are more
skillful than any others in judging
establishing and reducing to practice
the discoveries of barbarous nations
the jews then leading a groveling life
in some corner of palestine and being a
wholly uneducated people who had not
heard that these matters had been
committed to verse long ago by hesiod
and innumerable other inspired men wove
together some most incredible and
insipid stories that a certain man was
formed by the hands of god and had
breathed into him the breath of life and
that a woman was taken from his side and
that god issued certain commands and
that the serpent opposed these and
gained a victory over the commandments
of god thus relating certain old wives
fables and most impiously representing
god as weak at the very beginning of
things and unable to convince even a
single human being whom he himself had
formed
they speak in the next place of a deluge
and of a monstrous ark having within it
all things and of a dove and crow as
messengers falsifying and recklessly
altering the story of ducalian not
expecting i suppose that these things
would come to light but imagining that
they were inventing stories merely for
young children
the more modest among the jews and
christians endeavour somehow to give
these stories an allegorical
significance although some of them do
not admit of this but on the contrary
admit that they are exceedingly silly
inventions
the first point relating to the jews
which is fitted to excite wonder is that
they should worship the heaven and the
angels that dwell therein and yet pass
by and neglect its most venerable and
powerful parts such as the sun the moon
and the other heavenly bodies both fixed
stars and planets as if it were possible
that the whole could be god and yet its
parts not divine and i think that it
makes no difference whether you call the
highest being zeus or zen or adonai or
saboath or amon like the egyptians or
papayas like the scythians it is not
probable however that they enjoy god's
favor or are loved by him differently
from others or that angels were sent
from heaven to them alone as if they had
been allotted to some region of the
blessed
moreover their cosmogeny is extremely
silly the narrative of the creation of
man is exceedingly silly
perhaps moses wrote these words with no
serious object in view but in the spirit
of the writers of the old comedy who
have sportively related that protest
slew bellerophon and that pegasus came
from arcadia
moses and the prophets who have left us
our books not knowing at all what the
nature of the world is and of man have
woven together a web
of sheer nonsense
by far the most silly thing is the
distribution of the creation of the
world over certain days
before days
existed
for as the heaven was not yet created
nor the foundation of the earth yet laid
nor the sun yet revolving
how could there be days
and after accomplishing so much on the
first day to do so much more again on
the second and third and fourth and
fifth and sixth and after this indeed he
is weary like a very bad workman who
stands in need of a rest to refresh
himself
[Music]
christians at first were few in number
and held the same opinions but when they
grew to be a great multitude they were
divided and separated each wishing to
have his own individual party being thus
separated through their numbers they
confute one another still having so to
speak one name in common these things
are stated much better among the greeks
than in the scriptures and in a manner
which is free from all exaggerations and
promises on the part of god or the son
of
god you see how plato although
maintaining that the chief good could
not be described in words yet to avoid
the appearance of retreating to an
irrefutable position sub joins a reason
an explanation of this difficulty as
even nothing might perhaps be explained
in words
plato is not guilty of boasting and
falsehood giving out that he has made
some new discovery or that he has come
down from heaven to announce it but
acknowledges whence these statements are
derived
this saying it is easier for a camel to
go through the eye of a needle than for
a rich man to enter into the kingdom of
god manifestly proceeded from plato and
that jesus took the words of the
philosopher certain christians having
misunderstood the words of plato loudly
boast of a super celestial god thus
ascending beyond the heaven of the jews
and in all their writings is mentioned
made of the tree of life
and the resurrection of the flesh by
means of the tree because i imagine
their teacher was nailed to a cross and
was a carpenter by craft so that if he
had chanced to have been cast from a
precipice or thrust into a pit or
suffocated by hanging or had been a
leather cutter or a stone cutter or a
worker in iron there would have been
invented a precipice of life beyond the
heavens or a pit of resurrection or a
cord of immortality or a blessed stone
now what old woman would not be ashamed
to utter such things in a whisper even
when making stories to lull an infant to
sleep
certain most impious errors are
committed by them due to their extreme
ignorance in which they have wandered
away from the meaning of the divine
enigmas creating an adversary to god
the devil and naming him in the hebrew
tongue satan
now of a truth such statements are all
together of mortal invention and not
even proper to be repeated that the
mighty god in his desire to confer good
upon men has yet one counterworking him
and is helpless
the ancients do allude obscurely to a
certain war among the gods heraclitus
speaking of it
ferrocytes again who is much older than
heraclitus relates a myth of one army
drawn up in hostile array against
another and names chronos as the leader
of the one
the son of god is punished by the devil
and teaches us that we also when
punished by him ought to endure it
now these statements are altogether
ridiculous
for it is the devil i think who ought
rather to be punished and those human
beings were tricked by him or not to be
threatened with chastisement
let us pass on to another point
they cannot tolerate temples altars or
images in this they are like the
scythians the nomadic tribes of libya
the ceres who worship no god and some
other of the most barbarous and impious
nations of the world
but they charge those with folly who do
so because as i conjecture they do not
like the greeks suppose the gods to be
of the nature of men
god is the god of all alike
he
is good he stands in need of nothing and
he is without jealousy
what then is there to hinder those who
are most devoted to his service from
taking part in public feasts if these
idols are nothing what harm will there
be taking part in the feast on the other
hand if they are demons it is certain
that they too are god's creatures and
that we must believe in them sacrifice
to them according to the laws and pray
to them that they may be propitious
behold the christians say i go up to a
statue of jupiter and apollo or some
other god i revile it i beat it and yet
it takes no vengeance on me
do you not see good sir that even your
own demon is not only reviled but
banished from every land and sea and you
yourself who are as it were an image
dedicated to him abound and led to
punishment and fastened to the stake
whilst your demon or as you call him the
son of god takes no vengeance on this
evildoer
to some the gods have appeared in
visible forms the world is full of such
instances
you surely do not say that if the romans
were in compliance with your wish to
neglect their customary duties to gods
and men and were to worship the most
high or whatever you please to call him
that he will come down and fight for
them so that they shall need no other
help than his for this same god as
yourselves say promised of old this and
much more to those who served him and
see in what way he has helped them and
you
they in place of being masters of the
whole world are left with not so much as
a patch of ground or a home and as for
you if any of you transgresses even in
secret he is sought out and punished
with death
surely it is intolerable for you to say
that if our present rulers on embracing
your opinions are taken by the enemy you
will still be able to persuade those who
rule after them and after these have
been taken you will persuade their
successors and so on until at length
when all who have yielded to your
persuasion have been taken some prudent
ruler shall arise with a foresight of
what is impending and he will destroy
you all utterly before he himself
perishes if only it were possible that
all the inhabitants of asia europe and
libya greeks and barbarians all to the
uttermost ends of the earth were to come
under one law
but anyone who thinks this possible
knows nothing